on a des tesco tels des petits repas
koxie suis personne pour pour une nouvel
an mais bon beaucoup moins que les
autres années pour la période des fêtes
ce traiteur spécialisé dans la vente aux
entreprises a dû s'adapter situe à méré
dans les yvelines ce sont surtout des
particuliers aux alentours qui seront
servis pour le repas une charge de
travail beaucoup plus faible part
habituellement on embauche des
intérimaires
on est on doit être douze cuisiniers
plus des intérimaires ça court de
partout
là on est quatre aujourd'hui ça devient
bien diminuer les commandes pour des
cocktails et buffet en grand comité sont
normalement très nombreuses en cette
période
seulement un tiers du chiffre d'affaires
habituel de décembre sera réalisée cette
année là on est dans un principe un peu
click and collect comme beaucoup de
confrères et donc voilà ce sont les gens
une fois puces on l'a fait plutôt de la
communication de proximité et donc ce
sont des gens qui habitent aux alentours
qui viennent directement ils viendront
en tout cas demain à notre boutique pour
aller récupérer leurs
virer leurs prestations comme on l'a
fait pour le gérer pour jeudi 24 on a
fait exactement la même chose on a une
quarantaine de personnes qui sont venues
chercher leur banc une adaptation
nécessaire pour poursuivre l'activité
qui sera maintenue pour accélérer sa
transformation
l'entreprise travaille de plus en plus
avec des produits locaux objectif être
plus flexible en cas d'imprévu et
d'annulations de commandes
un nouveau champ d'activité parti pour
perdurer l'année prochaine on va
continuer dans cette démarche de ce
qu'on appelle de traiteur à domicile
et puis évidemment continuer à
travailler sur les entreprises avec
peut-être des phénomènes tout à fait
différent de livraison non plus en
entreprise mais à domicile
qu'est-ce que tout compte fait une
partie des travailleurs ou des salariés
vont encore être en télétravail et donc
potentiellement voilà sur des réunions
des animations des clips pour l'heure
c'est un nouvel an calme qui se profile
où des dizaines de commandes seront
quand même récupérer le matin du 31
décembre avec dans de nombreux colis
l'incontournable fois graff maison du
chef